[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN MCDOWELL: Welcome
to Google "Cloud OnAir,"
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Ryan McDowell.
AHMED ALTAY: And my
name is Ahmed Altay.
RYAN MCDOWELL: Today we're
going to be talking about stream
processing with Cloud Dataflow.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
We have Googlers on the
standby ready to answer them.
Let's get started.
Today we're going to talk
through stream processing,
common patterns with Dataflow,
the state and timer APIs
and how to take
advantage of them,
as well as streaming
with the Python SDK.
Before we dive
straight into patterns,
it's important to understand
why streaming matters
and how Apache Beam
and Dataflow help
you address some of
the common problems
within stream processing.
So we can have data
that we're processing
and that data can be big.
For instance, we could process
gigabytes to terabytes of data.
And that data could
be really, really big.
For instance, we
may want to process
huge amounts of data per day
and have many days to process.
That data could also
be infinitely big.
So you could be streaming data
and it's constantly coming
and it never stops.
This gives you a
problem with processing,
especially when accounting
for unknown delays
within your data.
So one of the more difficulties
with unbounded data
is unknown delays.
Assuming that every record
has an embedded timestamp,
hopefully, we would see the
records show up into our system
shortly after the event time.
Here's a record which
happened at 8:00 AM
and showed up in the
system shortly after.
Then we see this yellow
record that was slightly
delayed by a little bit.
And then finally, we
see this green record
on the right-hand side, which
is significantly delayed.
It had an event
timestamp of 8:00 AM,
but didn't show up into
our system until 2:00 PM.
There's many examples
why this may happen.
So for example,
imagine a mobile phone.
You maybe get into an airplane,
turn on airplane mode,
be playing your game
the entire time,
generating these game events.
And then when you
get off the plane,
you turn off airplane mode.
Then all the events at that
time shoot up to the cloud
and enter your pipeline.
So even though the events
had occurred much earlier,
they actually showed
up into your pipeline
much later than expected.
So the mobile world introduces
this delay in a pretty big way.
If you're performing
element wise
transforms, for
instance, filtering
for the yellow
messages, that's easy.
It's just a
continuous transform.
In this case, we
don't care about time.
We're not doing any
grouping or aggregation.
In this case, we don't care
that it's even an unbounded data
set.
Executing transforms
in processing time
will be just fine.
But what happens when we
want to do an aggregation?
We may want to see the
count of events per user.
For batch that's easy
because the data is bounded.
And essentially, we
read in the input
until we run out of input,
and then we emit the count.
For streaming,
you can't do that.
You never run out of the
data so you can't say,
we're done processing and
here's the count that I've seen.
Most commonly, what people
want to do is windowing,
so divide up the data into
some chunks, emit the count
for that particular chunk.
An initial approach
to doing this
would be using
processing time windows.
So for instance, when a
record shows up to our job,
look at the wall clock.
Do that for a minute,
and then say here
is the count for that minute.
There's many use cases
where that is fine.
But if you care about the time
stamp within your records,
you may not get the
grouping you actually want.
What we really may want to
do is group by the event
time within our data.
Instead of viewing time
as something on the wall,
view it as a data stream,
group by the event timestamps,
and output them as we see them.
This allows us to
perform calculations
over that time interval in
which the events occurred.
So for example, here,
taking the events
of when they occurred
in processing time,
and then shuffling them and
regrouping them into event time
windows, this allows
us to group data
by event time, which
would be semantically more
meaningful to our analytics.
So I mentioned windowing.
What is a window?
All a window is is a function
to divide data into time chunks.
Within the Apache Beam SDK,
which runs on Dataflow,
we provide several
different window types
which allow you
to slice and dice
your data in different ways.
These are some of
the more common ones.
So you have fixed windows, so
you can think of a fixed window
as dividing up data into
fixed periods of time.
So let's say 12:00 to
1:00, 1:00 to 2:00.
And then as soon as you
reach the end of that window,
compute your aggregation and
output a count for that window.
You also have sliding
windows and these
are sort of like fixed
windows that overlap.
So for instance, an element
could end up in many windows.
So say you have an hour window
that slides by every minute.
You may have a window that's
12:01 to 1:01, 12:02 to 1:02,
so on and so forth.
And this is useful for detecting
anomalies on the incoming data,
so for instance, determining
how many of a record
of a given type showed
up in our pipeline
within the past 10 minutes.
But what if we wanted to do
data-dependent windowing?
So not look at our
data in terms of time,
but look at it in
terms of something
that is meaningful
within our data,
such as doing different
windows for every user.
This is what we
would call sessions.
Here every key is
a different window.
And sessions are defined
by whenever there's
a burst of activity,
we're going to capture
that burst of activity.
And then as soon as there's
a gap in that activity,
we'll basically
close that window
and then emit it
downstream for processing
so that we can calculate
statistics over that window.
This is a common thing that you
may want to do in analytics,
and it's supported out of the
box within the Apache Beam SDK
and Cloud Dataflow.
So we talked about
windowing doing
and we talked
about, semantically,
how we would divide our data
up in computer calculations.
But when does the
answer come out?
This is problematic
because you have
to know when to
admit the answer.
And this is what we
use triggers for.
So by default, what we have is
something called the watermark.
The watermark tries
to know everything
about our data for
a particular window
and to know when we
are done with that.
So if the watermark says
12 o'clock, it means,
to the best of our
knowledge, there
is no data earlier
than 12 o'clock.
And then we can calculate
and emit the on-time result.
For external sources, it has
to be somewhat heuristic.
So for instance, Pub/Sub, we can
actually do ahead of the buffer
to ensure there's no data
left in it before 12 o'clock,
before we actually emit that.
But if there's a
mobile phone on a plane
and it has data for
11 o'clock in it,
clearly they don't
have any connectivity.
We cannot know about the
data that's on their phone.
So there has to be some
degree of heuristic to it.
It can't be perfect.
Just to the best
of our knowledge,
we can output a final
count and emit the results.
Here is an animated
GIF with the watermark
shown as a dotted line.
The y-axis is processing time
and the x-axis is event time.
The perfect watermark
will know about everything
that we haven't seen.
Perfect watermark
actually sees the future,
so it can capture data that
shows up significantly later
than we anticipated.
For the heuristic watermark, we
can see that it's pretty good.
But this one element, this 9:00
that showed up significantly
later, we didn't catch
it because we had closed
the window since
we would thought
we were done processing
data for that time period.
So what happens when
you have late data?
How do you handle it?
In the Apache Beam SDK,
there's a way of saying,
I want to process late data.
You can add triggering
to your window
to indicate you want to
process that late data.
So for instance,
there's a couple
of different ways
of processing it.
I can say, I want to accumulate
the processing, which
means keep adding to, let's
say, a sum or a count.
So if I had, let's say, a count
of 50 before and two elements
show up after the
watermark, then
they give me back a count of 52.
I can also say, [INAUDIBLE]
panes, which means,
give me a new sum since the
last time I emitted a result.
So if I saw 50 on-time
records and two elements
showed up late
after the watermark,
then just give me back the two.
This is another
animation which shows
how we do things with
speculative and late triggers.
We can output
tentative aggregations
before the watermark is past.
And then even with the
heuristic watermark,
we're able to update it
and update the result
and re-emit it downstream.
So it's sort of saying, sorry.
Here is the actual data that
I had for this time period.
And this allows us
to capture late data
and also emit speculative data
downstream to do our analytics.
So now that we understand
a little bit about how
stream processing works, let's
talk about common patterns
within Dataflow.
We'll start out with
exactly-once processing.
So imagine that we're
building a pipeline
to ingest gaming events
from our mobile game.
We'll start building
this pipeline
from the most simple case.
We want to ingest
JSON data via Pub/Sub,
process it within
Cloud Dataflow,
and then output it to BigQuery.
We're using Pub/Sub
here because it's
a reliable, globally available
message delivery service.
And we expect our game
to be popular worldwide.
Now, if we're analyzing
user behavior,
duplicate data which
enters our pipeline
may throw off our
analytics, which
makes exactly-once
processing fairly critical.
This is also critical
in other industries.
You could think of
retail where you
may be processing transactions
or finance in which you
may be processing trades.
Having duplicate data
enter your pipeline
and then computing on
that duplicate data
can throw off your analytics
and skew your data.
So if we're going to
zoom into the Pub/Sub
a portion of our
architecture, we
may presume that
it may cause issues
with our system, given
it's at-least once delivery
semantics.
Here the colors indicate
unique keys of records.
We can see that on
the right-hand side,
we may receive duplicates
in the subscriber given
the at-least once delivery.
However, combining
Pub/Sub with Dataflow
allows us to achieve
exactly-once processing out
of the box with little effort.
So how do we do that?
Well, imagine that we have
these three messages here.
This yellow message
we're zooming in on,
you can see that it contains
attributes and a payload.
Message attributes are
essentially key value pairs
that you can set on the
header of a message.
So you could think of setting
a key value pair to do things
like routing a message without
having to deserialize it,
or reacting to duplicates
within the pipeline.
The message payload contains
the serialized payload
of the event.
You'll see that we have
a unique identifier here
within the message
payload in event ID.
So the first step to
actually processing this data
in exactly-once fashion, we're
going to promote that event
ID to the attributes.
This allows us to
instruct Dataflow to react
to it within our pipeline.
If we take a look at the code
for our example game event
pipeline, it may look
like the following.
We're applying the
Pub/Sub I/O transform
to read the data
from our subscription
and pass it to our
transformations.
Here the transformations
represent ParDo functions.
You could think of a ParDo as
a map in MapReduce, essentially
taking in elements, do
some transformation on it,
and then output the
transformed element.
In this case, when we're
consuming from Pub/Sub I/O,
we're just reading the
messages from the subscription.
So how do we start
reacting to that event ID
that we promoted
to the attributes?
Well, it's relatively simple.
We just add in the
.withIdAttribute field and pass
in the key that we had put
in our message attributes.
This allows Dataflow to begin
reacting to these messages
and then, automatically
within the Pub/Sub I/O,
transform, be able
to de-duplicate
those messages
before sending them
downstream within our pipeline.
However, this will
effectively de-duplicate
messages introduced
by Pub/Sub, so
messages that are occurring as
duplicates within our system.
But there's also
another case in which
you may receive duplicates.
So for instance, a producer
publishes a message once
and then they publish
it again maybe,
let's say, several
minutes later.
This will also handle
that case, but only
within a 10-minute window.
So for instance, if a
publisher published the message
at minute one and then
published the same message
at minute three, we'll
effectively de-duplicate that.
But we don't keep around the
de-duplication table forever.
So if they were to publish
across multiple hours
of timeframes, then we may want
to introduce a unique transform
to our pipeline.
In this case, we don't
anticipate that being the case
so we can just de-duplicate
using the withId attribute.
So another common
pattern in Dataflow
is handling schema changes
from the source system.
For our mobile game
example, imagine
we have partners which publish
events into our pipeline.
There may be cases
where those partners add
an additional field
to the schema which
they are publishing.
We don't want it to be
dependent on those partners
and have to coordinate
releases, so we
want to react to
that dynamically
within our streaming pipeline.
Looking back at our
messages, on the left,
we see the schema
which we expect.
We have the same schema that
we were processing before.
But on the right-hand
side in the green message,
the partner has actually
added an additional field,
in this case, partnerDeviceIp.
Now, this additional field
will cause the insert to fail.
And this will cause us to
either drop the message
or continually failing
on that message.
Without accounting
for this, the record
will never make it into
our downstream system.
So we'll have to think about
how we handle this case.
Well, there's a couple of things
within BigQuery and Dataflow
that enable us to handle
this with relative ease.
So schema changes
within BigQuery
are additive within
the same table,
so you can add on fields
within that table.
And these changes happen
online and require no downtime.
So there's no effect
to downstream users
if we were to submit
an API call to add
an additional
column to our table
based on the incoming data.
And finally, the BigQuery
sink within Dataflow
allows for the retrieval
of failed inserts.
So this allows us to
submit records to BigQuery,
then get back all the failures,
and then react to them
and do things like add an
additional column to out output
table.
So zooming in our
pipeline code, we
can easily handle changes by
retrieving the failed inserts,
performing an update to
the schema in real time,
and then rewriting those
out to BigQuery again.
So handling changes
in this way enables
us to inspect each
message for schema changes
and then output the additions
to the BigQuery table.
Now, we could have done
this in a different way.
We could have checked
every single message
to see if its
schema had changed.
But this would have
been quite inefficient
because we would be checking a
bunch of messages that may not
have changed schema.
So you can imagine
that maybe I'm
processing data at
1,000 records per second
or a million records per second.
Inspecting all those
messages where they may not
have changed schema
will significantly
slow down the pipeline.
So doing it in this way allows
us to only inspect and mutate
the schema of those
messages which fail insert
and thus react to those
schema changes that
are happening upstream.
So looking back at
our pipeline now,
we've simply added
this additional path
to process those
errors, validate
and mutate the schema, and
then output to BigQuery.
And this reduces the
operational overhead
of coordinating changes
with our partners
and we can automatically update
our pipeline as changes occur.
So we've added a lot of
functionality to our pipeline
thus far.
Now we can utilize some of the
windowing techniques mentioned
earlier to perform
our user analysis.
Here we don't need to make any
adjustments to our architecture
since some of the strategies
that we had mentioned earlier
with windowing happen
within Dataflow,
nothing needed to add
to the architecture.
So an example of analysis
that we may want to perform
is how long a user
spent playing the game,
and possibly what caused the
user to stop playing the game.
Now, if we were to
utilize fixed windows,
we may run into problems
because if we are aggregating
over a fixed period of time,
let's say, from 12:00 to 1
o'clock, we may have multiple
users using the same device
and then grouping
those users together.
This grouping would
not be accurate
when performing things
like how long did
a user spend playing the
game, how many of events
of a given type did a
particular user incur.
And so it would give us
incorrect correlations
over our data.
So what we actually
want is sessioning.
With session windows, we can
achieve this per user windowing
and do analysis on each
of the individual users.
In this example, for
all elements for a key,
in this case, a user denoted by
these three different colors,
are included in the window
until a period of inactivity.
Once that period of
inactivity occurs,
we then fire off that window
and then produce our--
or calculate statistics
over that data.
In this case, it gives us
exactly the subdivisions
that we'd need.
So now looking at
our pipeline code,
we window into sessions
with a gap of five minutes.
So we'll capture
activity until we
don't see any activity for five
minutes for a particular user.
Then we'll key each individual
event by the user ID
so that we can do proper
groupings on our data.
And then we'll group that
data together and then perform
analysis on those
groupings of data.
So this enables us to
do things like answer
that question of how long
did a user play the game.
It also allows us to do
interesting things take
advantage of BigQuery's
nested and repeated fields,
for instance, grouping together
all records for a session
into a repeated field and
then having an aggregate data
record sent downstream.
So looking at our
updated pipeline,
we've now added this additional
path with form analysis.
You can see now that we're
sessioning by the user,
we're keying by that user before
we group that data together,
and then, finally, we
analyze those events
before we send them downstream.
AHMED ALTAY: OK.
So let's talk a little bit about
this state API and the timer
API in Beam.
Beam lets you process
unbounded large amounts of data
in a globally distributed
scale using the Beam's
portable [INAUDIBLE].
And stateful processing
along with timers
adds a new layer on top of it,
which enables new use cases
and opens up new efficiencies.
At its core, stateful
and timely processing
happens by augmenting
per element operations.
Per element operations
are just things
that we talk such as ParDos
by adding it mutable state
and also adding a
timer API access.
Stateful and timely computations
are the underlying patterns
that Beam builds up
on in other places.
Precisely because it is
the lower level APIs,
it allows you to
micromanage your pipelines
and your computations
to enable new use cases.
However, at the same
time, it's not magic.
By managing state
and timers, there
will be additional
complexes that's
built into your pipelines.
State API works by adding
scalability and consistency
on top of a fine-grained
stateful processing.
This is built on top
of Beam's portability.
It works by allowing
setting per key state
that's accessible within
per element transforms.
With this API, ParDos and any
other per element transforms
can access a mutable state
that is backed by a data store,
and can read and mutate these
data in a concurrent and safe
way.
And similarly, timer API
allows the stateful [INAUDIBLE]
to set timers, either in
the processing time domain
or in the event time
domain, to get callbacks
based on some timer event that's
customizable by the users.
And timer callbacks
also have access
to the same exact stateful APIs.
So let's look at the details
of the implementation.
So first thing is status
partitioned by key and window.
And what do we mean by
that is the stateful ParDo
in the middle of that pipeline
has access to a data store.
And given an element,
the runner will
autodetect the window
and the key that's
associated with that element.
And that stateful ParDo will
be able to access the state
cell within this data store.
And why is it important
that state is partitioned
along the windowing domain
in addition to the key domain
is this allows
runners to clean up.
Once windows expires,
it's possible for runners
to go and clean up
the state store.
This is really important
because otherwise, the runners
will have [INAUDIBLE]
state forever
during the runtime
of department.
There are additional
considerations
that comes with partitioning
this state per key
and per window.
One consideration is since
there are concurrency guarantees
and the partitioning
happens per key
and per window, that could mean
that a runner need to shuffle
data to a single worker
in order to execute
within the context of a
per key and per element.
So there are two
implications to that.
The first implication is
there could be shuffling.
The second implication
is that there
is a limit to parallelization.
It's possible that within
the same key and same window,
the runner will be forced
to execute serially.
And the other
implication of this
comes in the storage and
fault tolerance area.
Since we are partitioning
per key and per window,
that means that the state
store needs to keep state
per key and per window.
If there will be a lot
of keys and windows,
that means that there will
be a proportional increase
in this storage used.
And the correllator
of that is if you
want to get a lot of
parallelism into your system,
you could partition a lot within
the key or within the window
or in any combination
of those two.
So let's look at an example
to clarify a little bit.
Here we are talking about,
you can get a regular DoFn.
It takes a key value input
and returns some other thing.
And the first thing
that you will notice
is there is a tag,
your state ID,
which uses an identify index.
Here index is a
mutable state cell
that is partitioned
by key and window.
And if you go down a little bit
and look at the process element
function, in the
argument list, you
will see the same state ID
tag with a matching index
identifier.
At execution time,
runner will pass
us the state cell
that we can access
and because of the
matching identifiers,
it will be the exact
same thing as we defined.
If you look at the body
of the process function,
it is a treeline function.
First thing you should
notice is the second line
is just a regular DoFn syntax.
It is outputting an element
based on its inputs.
The first line within
the [INAUDIBLE] body,
it's reading an integer that
is stored in the state cell.
And the third line is
updating this value
by writing it on top of it.
Since Beam runners provides
the concurrency guarantees,
writing into the same state
will be guaranteed to not try it
on top of undefined values.
Another thing I would
like to talk about here
is the type of state.
If you notice, the type
of state, the index,
is an integer here.
And since I said
that the runners may
need to shuffle
data across workers,
the state value needs
to be serializable.
In this case, the integer
value is serializable
and we are using a variant
caller to ensure that.
So the important
part to get here
is whatever you put in
your state, it's up to you.
However, it needs to
have a caller that
could serialize the type
of your state information.
Let's tie this a little
bit with the timer API.
What does timer API do?
Any stateful DoFn
could set timers,
and timers could be triggered
in the processing time
or in the event time.
So what do we mean by that?
Timers could be triggered
within the processing time.
That means that a
stateful DoFn can
set a timer that will trigger,
let's say, a minute from now.
Or a stateful DoFn can set
a timer in the event time,
and what that could mean is
it DoFn could request a timer
to trigger random timestamps
of elements being processed
reaches a certain timestamp.
Timing events has access to
the same state information
and have access to the
same mutable state data.
And in combination, they are
not really powerful scenarios.
So this is a combined example
we are looking at right now.
And again, this is a
regular DoFn function.
It's this stateful
DoFn function.
You can notice the state ID
tags on a bunch of variables.
And one thing that's different
here is the timer ID tag.
We are using timer ID tag
to create a new timer.
In this case our timer has
an identifier called expiry.
And the other thing
to notice here
is timer was created in
the event time domain.
So that means that we
can't use this timer
to set triggers that will
trigger in the event time
domain.
If you look at our process
method, in the argument list,
there would be one
[INAUDIBLE] argument
that is the timer ID tag with
the same exact identifier
expiry.
Our Beam runner will
pass us this timer
and it will do the
matching [INAUDIBLE]
based on the matching
identifier of expiry.
Within the body
of the DoFn, it is
possible to do any of
your regular DoFn logic.
After that, before that,
or in between that,
you can access state
APIs and timer APIs.
In this case, the
DoFn is setting
a timer that's going to trigger
after the end of the window
plus some allowed lateness.
And one thing I would
like to point out here
is we are setting this timer
within the process element
function, and this is
happening for every element.
This is fine because
setting and resetting
timers in Beam timer APIs is
not an expensive operation.
Let's go down a little bit to
look at our callback method.
Their method called onExpiry
will be our callback method.
And Beam runners identify
this and understand this
by the tag onTimer.
OnTimer tags tags our callback
method used by the action
of using the same
identifier-- that's expiry--
Beam runner can match this
callback event to the timer
that we were already using.
And within the argument list
of this callback method,
you will notice that
it actually has access
to one of the state
in the state cells.
So this is because timer
callbacks have regular access
to the state APIs.
And to summarize what's
happening within this callback
method, it is reading some input
information from the state,
adding some management,
and outputting as usual.
So in combination, this example
uses state API, timer API,
demonstrate callbacks,
and demonstrate
use of state and timer tags.
I would also like to talk a
little bit about the Python SDK
within Beam, within the context
of the Dataflow streaming.
Python streaming is one
of their latest offerings.
Python streaming beta was
launched in July 2018.
From alpha to beta we made
significant improvements
in performance and
stability, and in terms
of the amount of Beam
model of that is supported.
In its current state, Python
streaming SDK for Apache Beam
supports all of Beam model.
It allows reading
from Cloud Pub/Sub.
It allows writing
to Cloud Pub/Sub
and it allows writing
to Cloud BigQuery.
And what is on our roadmap?
One thing that's
on our roadmap is
continuing to improve
performance and stability
of Python streaming.
The next thing is
we are planning
to add more and more I/Os.
That is adding support for
other Google Cloud data sources
and as well as other
open source data
sources such as Apache Kafka.
Another feature that
is on the roadmap
is called cross
language transforms.
This is one of the
most exciting features.
Cross language transforms
allow accessing
to transforms or I/Os that are
written in other languages.
With cross language
transforms, it
will be possible to
use Python SDK to use
any of the areas that
were already developed
and has been used for a
while within the Java SDK.
So this will open
up Python SDK users
to a large new set of I/Os.
The next thing we
have on our roadmap
is adding support for all
the Cloud Dataflow service
features.
These are the
coolest features that
make people use managed Cloud
Dataflow servers to execute
their Beam pipelines.
So one of those
features is autoscaling.
Autoscaling allows picking just
the right amount of workers
automatically for
Cloud Dataflow jobs.
So this will be
one of the features
that we are planning to
add for Python streaming.
And finally, Python 3 support.
This is a longtime
requested feature.
We are building this
into the Python streaming
and also for Python batch.
And this is one of the--
this concludes one of the major
items that's on our roadmap.
And I would also like to
talk about runners, where you
can run Python streaming today.
You can run Python streaming
SDK on Cloud Dataflow.
This is supported
at the beta level.
You can use the DirectRunner
for local execution.
DirectRunner is a
really cool feature
that's a pretty
complete runner that
can execute Python SDK pipelines
within a single computer.
It's great for testing and
developing new pipelines.
And another thing is that
there is work going on
to enable Python
streaming SDK to work
on other open-source runners.
Apache Flink will
be one of them.
So this will just expand on
the synergy of Apache Beam
by combining other open-source
projects together and tying
them together.
So let's look at how a
Python streaming WordCount
example works.
The first thing to notice
within this example
is it is the usual
batch WordCount example
with just a few differences.
The very first difference
is the first line.
That is a read that's an I/O
operation to read from Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub is
streaming source
and we are subscribing
to a subscription
here to read incoming
messages as they come along.
So this will be a streaming job.
And as long as the
job is running,
it will be reading new
messages from Cloud Pub/Sub
as they arrive.
The other difference that
I would like to point out
is the second to last line.
That is a write operation
to Cloud Pub/Sub.
Again, Cloud Pub/Sub
as a streaming pipe.
And reading and writing into
that requires a streaming job.
In this case, once the
inputs are processed,
we are writing them
back into the Cloud
Pub/Sub in a streaming fashion.
Beyond that, there are
really no other differences.
It is read from an
I/O that is streaming,
do the usual
processing, write back
to an I/O that
supports streaming.
And just a quick
highlight for the people
who are not very familiar
with the Python SDK here
is [INAUDIBLE] is the transform
that we use for windowing.
That is the same
thing that we started
talking about at the beginning
of this presentation.
The other interesting
thing here is
group by key, which respects
the windowing as it's
defined in the previous
[INAUDIBLE] transform,
and groups element
into the categories
that's based on the
key and the window.
And finally, all
the other transforms
that are mentioned here--
Map, ParDo-- are
element-based transforms.
they do operation based
on a given element
and they produce some
number of output elements.
And to tie up with
the previous segment,
Beam Python SDK
currently doesn't
have support for
state and timer APIs,
but that's one of the things
that's on our feature list
that we would like to add as
we advance to our roadmap.
So with that, we conclude the
Python streaming-related part.
So stay tuned for live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
All right.
Thank you for the questions.
So I will read the
questions from the audience
and start answering them.
The first question is, what
kind of windows do I have?
Is it limited fixed,
sliding, and session windows?
In Beam, windowing
is just an API.
It's possible to build any sort
of custom windowing functions
that satisfies your use case.
Beam, by default, comes with
these three type of windows--
fixed, sliding, and session.
But there is no limit on how to
build or what kind of windows
to use.
You can look at
some of our examples
to find how to build
your own custom windows.
The next question is,
what are some tradeoffs
with various triggers?
Triggers at its core
allow you to customize
three things-- one, latency;
second, cost; and third,
accuracy.
Think of a use
case where you are
trying to show the top 10 users
for a mobile game leaderboard.
What you probably
need is low latency
so that your users
show new data quickly,
accuracy might not
be very important,
and you probably want
to reduce your costs.
And in a different case--
let's say this is a building
example--
that you want to get
amount of full billing
at the end of the month.
In this case, probably latency
doesn't matter that much.
If you get your
data an hour later,
the month ends will be OK.
But you really
want full precision
in terms of how your
billing comes out.
And cost probably
doesn't matter that much.
So triggers allow
you to customize
in these three dimensions.
RYAN MCDOWELL: The next
question is, where do I
go to find more examples?
So the Apache Beam
SDK on GitHub actually
has an examples directory.
And within this
directory, you can
find examples for simple
things like WordCount
all the way up to complex things
like running some processes
within a ParDo function.
We also provide
Dataflow templates.
So Dataflow templates are
selectable on the Cloud Console
UI within a dropdown.
So say you're ingesting
data from Pub/Sub
and you just want to
output that to BigQuery.
You don't really have
that many transformations
that you want to
do, you just want
to get that data
into your system.
You can go to the
Dataflow Console UI
and just select that
from a dropdown.
But we also publish
these templates
on GitHub underneath the
Google Cloud Platform Dataflow
Templates repository.
The next question is, what are
some other common patterns?
Well, we actually
have a blog series
on common patterns
within Cloud Dataflow.
You can find these within the
Google Cloud Platform blog.
I believe they're called
"Use Case In Patterns--
Common Use Cases In Patterns
Within Cloud Dataflow."
Just to mention some
of the other ones
that you may find
there, should be
like "Dealing With Bad
Data," "How Do I Make Calls
To an External Database," "How
Do I Merge Windows Together,"
and "How Do I Handle Composite
Keys" for a group by key.
So check out those blogs to
find out more information
about the common
patterns within Dataflow.
AHMED ALTAY: The next question
is, where is state stored?
And traditionally,
in Dataflow there's
an agent that handles
storing of state.
And how it was
implemented, initially,
was it used local disks
of the virtual machines.
However, with the introduction
of streaming engines,
some of these things are stored
in its own cloud service.
So it depends on what you use.
It's possible that your
local disk is used.
Or depending on if you are
using streaming engine,
it will be stored in
another cloud service.
RYAN MCDOWELL: The
next question is,
when do I use the state API
versus another hosted service?
So as you can imagine, storing
state in the pipeline itself,
when do I use that
versus storing state
in an external store
such as Cloud BigTable
or Redis, our memory store.
Well, essentially, storing
the state within your pipeline
allows you to have low
latency reads and writes
from that state.
And it allows you
to keep that state
only for a particular
period of time, so
say, during your window.
So if you're using
another hosted service,
you may accumulate
that state over time
and have to do manual cleanup.
Another benefit of this
is that Dataflow actually
manages the state for you.
As you saw in the code
earlier, all I call
is read states or write states.
I don't have to worry about
setting up any infrastructure.
managing that infrastructure
or monitoring it because it's
all handled on the backend
by Google Cloud's
Dataflow service.
AHMED ALTAY: And the
last question on the list
is, what are the limitations of
state API in terms of latency,
size, or anything else?
As we just talk in one of
our previous questions, state
itself is stored either
on a local disk or
and that different service.
So I think a lot of
size to your state
will mean that a
considerable amount of data
is moving just because
it's part of the state.
So if you're in
one of these cases,
you could consider
re-architecting
your [INAUDIBLE] such
that some of this data
is actually part of
your main input data.
In terms of latency,
again, the state
needs to be shuffled
at [INAUDIBLE]..
So there will be some
amount of latency,
but it will not be a
considerable amount.
And the final thing that you
should be considering is,
as we mentioned during
our presentation,
is that the state data itself
needs to be serializable.
So as long as you pick a
type that is serializable,
you can use any type of
[INAUDIBLE] for your state.
So with that, we
[INAUDIBLE] the questions.
RYAN MCDOWELL: Stay tuned
for the next section--
"How API Products Accelerated
Walgreens' Digital
Transformation To the Cloud."
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]